getting it into horford horford catches
kicks dort for the win
it's good
and lou dort ends it
and the mob converges
the officials saying don't leave the
floor yet
and let's make sure it's official
and by just a brilliant play by mark
dagenhall
and brutally executed by the thunder
players
because the most unlikeliest guy to take
the shot
well i'm thinking well you want the ball
in the hands of shea or you want the
ball in the hands of al horford
but lou dort takes the shot and knocks
down
the game winner man this is one of those
things you just
take this home all right let's send it
over to nick who is standing by
with the man of the night lou
congratulations on the game-winner
all right let's send it over to nick who
is standing by with the man of the night
lou congratulations on the game winner
what did that feel like as that shot
went up
and it felt good uh i kind of knew that
was going to over help an hour and i
had to be ready to knock it down so you
know i was ready to and i did i made it
you hit a bunch of threes in that fourth
quarter really the shot making all
around was
incredible what was this like to gut out
this win as a team
i mean uh we we had a slow start you
know oh man even you know shay got us
going
the whole time and we had to step up
with him and you you know uh
at the end of the fourth quarter you
know we just had to make plays and we
did you mentioned shea he had 21 of his
42 in that third quarter
what was he doing out there to be able
to just get into the teeth of the
defense and find ways to score
i mean he's our leader you know it
wasn't going down for us at first and
you know
he just took over and you know we need
our leader to do that
lou all of the work that you've put into
your game how rewarding does this feel
to be knocking down three-pointers
knocking down your very first game
winner
i mean it's big it's big you know all
the time that i spent in the gym and you
know working on stuff like that
and you know i just i just had to be
ready you know i missed i missed one
against uh the lakers a couple weeks ago
you know and
just when i was ready last thing for you
this is a tough stretch five games and
seven nights you got a back to back
coming up
what's the mindset and mentality of this
group right now you know to take care of
our body
at first and uh you know and play that
play as a team you know if you play
together we can win any games
thanks luke congrats on the win thank
you
what a play what a finish what a game
and
oklahoma city prevailing tonight thanks
to the game-winner out of that man's
hands
lou dort who caps it off with a
beautiful
three-point finish and she goes
alexander and his career high
42 and the thunder will head back to the
locker room and celebrate this one